CARTER MORGAN: Kubernetes
is amazingly powerful.
But if you're just
getting started,
it might also seem
amazingly complicated.
So let's learn how
to debug applications
running on Kubernetes.
Hi, Kaslin.
Thanks for coming by.
I've been learning a
lot about Kubernetes
from you, about pods and
services, containers and more.
And they mostly
work pretty well.
But what do I do when
things aren't working?
KASLIN FIELDS: Oh,
that's a great question.
Learning how to debug Kubernetes
is very useful, especially
because applications on
Kubernetes can grow so large,
it can be very
difficult to know what's
going on in your system
at any given time.
CARTER MORGAN: Exactly.
If I was just doing
everything manually
and only had a
few instances, I'd
know how and where to look
for the information I need.
But with Kubernetes
abstracting away
the infrastructure
behind the application,
I don't even know
where to start.
KASLIN FIELDS: Well, let's
start with what you do know.
How do you currently
debug Kubernetes?
CARTER MORGAN: The
kubectl command line tool
is some useful tooling
I've been using.
I found them using
kubectl --help,
but my favorites so far
are kubectl explain,
kubectl describe,
kubectl logs, and kubectl
get with the -o flag.
KASLIN FIELDS: How
do you use those?
CARTER MORGAN:
Well, I use kubectl
explain whenever I come
across a new API object
that I don't know.
What's especially
nice about it is
how I can dig into
the documentation
of specific fields, too.
So it's like a one-stop command
line shop for defining objects.
Kubectl logs is
useful because it
lets me see what's
happening inside of a pod.
It logs events from
containers and stores
them so I can
easily access them.
Then I use the trusty kubectl
describe to look at pod states
and events.
KASLIN FIELDS:
That's a great start.
Kubectl describe
can tell you a lot.
For instance, if
a pod is pending,
that could mean you have
insufficient resources that
prevent the pod from getting
scheduled onto a node.
CARTER MORGAN: So
maybe in that case,
I could delete another
pod or create a new node
to make space.
KASLIN FIELDS: Yeah, that might
be a good way to handle it.
Another state a pod can be
in is the waiting state.
CARTER MORGAN: Oh,
I have seen that.
KASLIN FIELDS:
Yeah, that happens
when a pod has been scheduled
onto a node, but it can't run.
For instance, maybe the
image can't be pulled.
So even though there's
space to run the app,
it just won't work.
CARTER MORGAN: Hmm.
What about other cases, like
if there's space to run the app
and the image is working,
but the app itself is broken?
I'm not sure how to debug that.
KASLIN FIELDS: For
cases like that,
kubectl exec is your friend.
CARTER MORGAN: Oh,
let me look that up.
Kubectl exec lets me execute
a command in a container
or even open an interactive
shell in the container.
Wow, that's useful.
KASLIN FIELDS: So if
you needed to dig around
inside of your
application, maybe
to see where files
are being stored
or what ports are accessible
inside the container,
exec is a really
useful tool for that.
CARTER MORGAN: Mm, OK.
So to summarize, depending
on the state my pod is
in-- whether it's
pending, waiting,
or otherwise running
but somehow failing--
that determines what
my issue might be.
KASLIN FIELDS: Yes, and by
using logs, the exec command,
and other very
simple commands, you
can generally find
out enough information
to troubleshoot
your application.
CARTER MORGAN: Wow,
thanks again to Kaslin
for always dropping knowledge.
In this episode, we learned a
lot about debugging Kubernetes
application.
For more information,
check out the links
in the description below.